honey guys Greg Rajan Superbowl is
around the corner
oh boy that they've already released a
Super Bowl TV spot for transformers the
last night who are you going to vote for
for the Super Bowl
ah Hillary Hillary now let's do this
what why they keep coming here
yeah actually whoa damn I will be
looking like you got one up on Optimus
there oh my that's not like a battle
extended TV spot on Sunday well of
course yeah for the big Super Bowl
football game that looks cool it does
look cool it looks like they're really
taking it and making it something
distinct now I found out earlier this
morning that the guys who wrote this one
wrote the first Iron Man movie really so
this could be better actually well you
know I feel like if you look at across
the scope of these big blockbuster
movies you could argue that right now
the lesson that they're all learning is
oh we got to do kind of what maybe
Marvel but like Fast and the Furious did
where we figure out around par-5 how to
change the ranch eyes to keep it alive
like people don't want to just see the
same movie so what are we going to do to
make it different and yeah he's like
that's going hardcore into the dystopia
you know the future exactly I mean
that's something that this imagery
really showed me every time we go to
catch up on transformers it's like how
the world still normal
this is [ __ ] you know just epic on
date I don't New York again yeah they
should everything is back to normal this
one looks like things have kind of are
going into ruins a little bit yeah Mark
Wahlberg looks like [ __ ] Conan the
Barbarian I wonder if he's the last
night he could be the last wielding a
sword why do they need his help because
he's tiny I just can't wait till they
get Shia LaBeouf back we over do do like
a soft 7 about it this looks like it
could be cool as much as I don't love
watching just like things I know
or fake or fake in what's supposed to be
a real world just punch each other a lot
I don't love these movies and I'm not
going to keep that a secret but if they
can make this into something that's
actually cool out I would be happy to
see that you know they're really teasing
this bumblebee versus Optimus fight yeah
I know everyone's Batman vs Superman
right now yeah uh yeah that could be
cool you know an innocent versus like a
noble leader guy or the last trailer
showed us that Optimus was owning and
this one it's like Oh bumblebees kind of
owning in this fight yeah who's gonna
win man who's gonna win wants it more I
think they should kill off bumblebee I
think that would be a great step in the
franchise if they just kill up on Bobby
now they should like everyone's favorite
transformer they should just make it so
that he's only a car forever and he goes
and live the Shia love it a second one
is coming monster trucks
oh yeah he's been on serious for
families it's perfect and Optimus has
got like these purple eyes going on
showing he's possessed yeah yeah yeah oh
my controlled or something mana yeah is
his programming has changed or something
looks like Terminator aliens yeah I like
the apocalyptic bond yeah I like the
upon dirt and then already saw these
guys who are riding it already announced
to write the next like three transformer
movies yeah oh boy oh I really feel like
they're doing like what fast and furious
they were like okay with the film we're
gonna just go in a completely different
direction but yeah change this every so
often and find ways of keeping it
distinct and like that yeah that's cool
yeah I I like this kind of stuff and now
I just hope that it's an actual movie
that's the one thing that I just don't
have enough face in them to do is like
are you gonna make this like a real
movie that opening sequence was just
like wet swirling and the cure for
Huelva strain is you've done horrible
things well I'll make sure to check out
the Super Bowl TV spot John's gonna be
busy day everyone's gonna be at Super
Bowl parties I'm not I'm getting junker
you'll be so many so many but I am gonna
wait around in my apartment for trailers
to draw yes for you guys things to do
for you guys I'm not going to join any
fun
well it's talking versus pager is amid
you really care about that magic no no
not at all he gives the Falcons I don't
know it's some bird it's one of the
burning Gary
the halftime shows I I'm like I don't
give a [ __ ] about the Superbowl but you
do what I do to the Super Bowl parties
I'm like not being a title in here but
is again either you'll be doing
something constructive and you will be
truly winning well everybody else was
one team win a football game you will be
winning it like yeah I'll be alone my
heart rying to work waiting for some
Hollywood you know intern I just want to
get invited somewhere Lee wanna be able
to say no I can I can subscribe to the
real reject Tom's reasons to Jenna
Twitter Instagram social media manager
Facebook the real rejects and bloom
house put down requests for more but you
want to check out facebook.com slash the
real rejects request yeah go there like
a DJ because I don't like skimming
through comments cuz I could read nine
positive comment didn't I read one
negative and it just ruined my day and I
take all my anger out on job it'll help
you request that much more if it doesn't
also hurt our self-esteem yeah also you
know if you leave a mean comment there's
a speedy but it were just those hide
this users comedy you've never comment
again as you create another account to
comment and then you're just loser for
you